there is an entire dow a bunch of
strangers millions of them millions of
people around the world are all going to
come together they're going to try to
create a dao and they're going to try to
buy the us constitution starting this
week a dao a decentralized autonomous
organization is being formed it's called
the constitution dao they've registered
with sotheby's and they've already gone
through all the kyc measures that they
need to in order to pull funds and make
a run at winning the auction for one of
the copies of the u.s constitution that
is going to be auctioned off later this
week now this dow has already raised a
pretty significant amount of money but
why exactly do they need to have the dao
the dao why is it a dow decentralization
and cryptocurrency web 3 have created
structures that allow people to
self-govern with unparalleled levels of
autonomy and freedom it's fitting that
we use this technology to honor and
protect the greatest historical tool for
human governance the us constitution so
decentralized they're trying to
self-govern and they are trying to go
and make a run at buying the us
constitution now out of their frequently
asked questions two specific things that
i thought most people would be
interested in one what's going on
they're buying the us constitution
they're attempting to buy for the first
time in 33 years one of the 11
surviving copies of the official edition
from the constitutional convention will
be publicly auctioned by sotheby's it is
the only copy that is still owned by
private collectors the proceeds from the
auction will be given to a charity that
has been established by the current
owner the constitution dao is pulling
together money to win the auction they
intend to put the constitution in the
hands of the people what will happen to
the constitution constitution dao
seeking an esteemed esteemed partner to
display the constitution the eventual
home must have the expertise to properly
house store and maintain this artifact
additionally the community has expressed
strong preferences for institutions that
are free to the public and willing to
cover the costs associated
associated with housing the document so
yesterday [ __ ] mccormick he wrote a
piece on this and at that time he said
it's not a move it's not a moment it's a
movement and he said that 8 000 people
were already in the discord 3 million
committed in 12 hours 10 plus million
dollars in soft commits and the auction
house on thursday night ready to rock
and roll are they going to be able to
get it or not well they have about 26
percent of their goal already achieved
they're trying to raise 20 million
dollars to do this they've got over 5
million dollars already raised they're
gonna take a run at it now a couple of
thoughts one i love the idea of the
people right up in that air quotes
however you want to think about that
going and actually buying a addition of
the constitution and then using a
democratically uh kind of driven process
to figure out where should we put it it
should be available to anybody should be
free and also there should be an ability
for anyone in the world to show up and
actually see it and learn about what the
constitution's all about
second is that the whole concept of
being able to very quickly pool funds et
cetera there's risk there's all sorts of
legal questions that go into this i
don't want to get into any of that i'm
not an expert on it that's all going to
get figured out by other people but i do
think that it's very interesting that
sotheby's has already gone ahead and
gotten them through that kyc process so
that's one step towards what their
ultimate goal is if they are able to
pull this off i think that it would be
very very interesting this would be kind
of a warning shot to the rest of the
world wait a minute what the hell is
going on with these things